imagine standing at the origin of an
infinite number line
you begin flipping a fair coin that
tells you where you should move
if you get tails you take one step to
the left and if you get heads
one step to the right this is a random
walk in one dimension and more
specifically this is a symmetric
random walk where we have equal
probability of moving in either
direction
we can generalize this type of walk to
any number of dimensions
randomly selecting a unit step in any
axis direction
so in two dimensions we can take a step
along the x or y axis
and in three dimensions along the x y or
z axis
in the early 1900's hungarian
mathematician
george poglia was interested in the
following question
once we begin our random walk are we
guaranteed to eventually return
to where we started we might think that
if we walk forever we'll surely come
back at some point
however long it takes but when it comes
to infinity
our intuitions can mislead us it turns
out while this is correct in the
one and two dimensional cases in three
dimensions this is suddenly no
longer true and in fact it's more likely
that we never return
our probability of returning drops from
a clean one
to .34 as it's often summarized
a drunk man will find his way home but a
drunk bird
may get lost forever now you're probably
asking why
why this abrupt change in behavior as we
jump from two dimensions
to three sure as we move to higher
dimensional space we have
more choices for our steps and it makes
sense that it would probably take
longer to return but to never return
that's strange in this video
we'll try to gain some intuition about
this awesome result
known as polia's recurrence theorem
let's first formalize the question a bit
let s
n be our location at step n then
sn is the sum of each of our individual
steps x
i as i ranges from 1 to n
each step x i is drawn uniformly among
the axis aligned unit steps
so for a given dimension d there are two
times d
possible steps and each has an equal
chance of selection
now familiarity with markov chains won't
be required to understand anything in
this video
but if you have seen them before you
know that we can view the walk as a
markov chain
with an infinite set of possible states
every d
dimensional lattice point with
transition probabilities 1 over 2d
for jumping to each neighboring state
and 0 for jumping to any farther state
we're concerned with this probability
the probability
of returning to the origin at least once
if this probability equals 1 the origin
will be called a recurrent state
but if there's some non-zero chance of
never returning
it's transient suppose the origin is
known to be recurrent
then when we eventually do return we
will basically begin a brand new walk
again with the guarantee of returning
naturally we might expect to visit the
origin
infinitely many times over an infinite
time frame
for these types of systems this
condition turns out to be both necessary
and sufficient
we have recurrence if and only if the
expected number of returns
is infinite let's take a look at some
walks in one dimension
and see if we notice anything about
their behavior
we'll set a hundred walkers to each take
10 steps and record their final
positions
one thing we see of course is that since
we had an even number of time steps
we have zero walkers on the odd
coordinates but there also seems to be a
higher concentration of walkers near the
origin
let's try a thousand steps with ten
thousand walkers
our walkers are more spread out now but
we still see this bell-shaped curve
which may remind you of a normal or
gaussian distribution
the central limit theorem tells us that
the distribution of the sum
of independent and identically
distributed random variables
with finite mean and variance ultimately
converges to a normal distribution
well we definitely meet those conditions
here the mean of our two step choices
is zero and our squared step length is
always one
so if the sum of our individual steps is
approaching a normal distribution
what is its width how far do we expect
to get
let's compute the average squared
distance from the origin at step n
this is also equivalent to the variance
of sn because
sn is a centered random variable the
expected position
no matter how many steps we take is
still zero the origin
the squared distance will just be the
square of the sum of our steps
linearity of expectation allows us to
bring the expectation operator
inside these two summations
we already know that the square of each
step length is one
but what is the expectation of x i times
xj
that is the product of two independent
steps
well half the time the step directions
will be the same
and half different likewise the product
is
negative one or one with equal frequency
so the expectation of this product is
zero and overall
we end up with a sum of n ones
so our average square distance is just n
and our root mean squared distance the
standard deviation of sn
is the square root of n you're likely
familiar with the
6895 99.7 rule
where we expect 68 95 and 99.7
of the values of a normal distribution
to lie within one
two and three standard deviations of the
mean respectively
so let's first think heuristically about
our probability of being at the origin
at a given step since it's only possible
to return
in an even number of steps we'll ask
what's the probability of returning on
step
2n well if our distribution is
approximately normal
we expect to end up within one standard
deviation of the mean
the majority of the time for two n steps
our standard deviation is radical two n
and there are about
two times radical two n positions within
this distance from the origin
with half of them being even if we treat
these options uniformly
we might guess that our probability of
being at the origin is on the order of
1 over radical 2n now this constant is
probably a bit off because
we only expect to be within this
interval 68
of the time and in truth we should have
a bit more probability mass
for positions closer to the origin but
it turns out this is a pretty good
approximation
to be a little more accurate let's
determine how many possible trajectories
there are
of length two n for each step we have
two choices
negative and positive so that's two
raised to the two nth power
distinct trajectories how many of these
have us back at the origin
at step 2 n well such a trajectory would
be required to have exactly as many
negative steps
as positive steps we can simply focus on
which steps will be designated as
positive while the rest will be negative
so how many ways are there to select n
indices out of 2n
total indices that would be the binomial
coefficient
2n choose n so our probability of being
back at the origin
is 2n choose n over 2 to the 2n
the number of suitable trajectories
divided by the total number of
trajectories
great but now we have several factorials
which are difficult to evaluate
to help we can bring in sterling's
formula which is known to be
asymptotically equivalent to the
factorial
the derivation for sterling's formula is
a bit involved and deserves its own
separate video
at the moment let's just take it off the
shelf and plug it in
after simplifying we end up with this
one over radical pi
n so we were pretty close the
probability decreases proportionally
to 1 over radical n with this in hand
let's evaluate the expectation of the
number of visits
in one dimension the summand here is an
indicator variable where it equals 1 if
s2n
is the origin and 0 otherwise
we end up with a p series where p our
power
is one half if we remember from calculus
a p
series with p less than or equal to one
ends up diverging because the summand
decreases too slowly
regardless of any constant factor
multiplying it
the expected number of returns to the
origin is therefore infinite
and our probability of returning is one
what happens in two dimensions consider
two one-dimensional walkers taking steps
simultaneously
one confined to the x-axis and the other
to the y-axis
this is actually equivalent to a single
two-dimensional walk
but rotated by 45 degrees and slightly
rescaled
back to the origin requires both walkers
to return
at the exact same time step if we take
the expected number of returns now
our p series has power one grows like
the harmonic series
and diverges again
you might guess where this is going is a
three-dimensional walk equivalent to
three simultaneous one-dimensional walks
well it isn't exactly an actual
three-dimensional walk has six
options at each step two for each of the
three axes
but three one-dimensional walks have
eight possible options at each step
still for the purposes of recurrence the
behavior is equivalent
we won't do the full derivation here
which is a bit more involved than in one
and two dimensions
but the return probability for the
three-dimensional walk on step two n
ends up decreasing proportionally to n
to the negative three halves
our p series now has a power greater
than one and converges
in 3d we expect to only return a finite
number of times
in these calculations we focused on the
origin but it's easy to see that in
one and two dimensions every other
location will be visited as well
why consider some point a and a single
path from the origin
to a for example in one dimension this
could be the straight line path from the
origin to a
well every time we're at the origin
we'll have
some positive probability of following
this path
and therefore visiting a if we view this
as a bernoulli trial
where success is defined as following
this path
we'll have probability of one of getting
a success over an infinite number of
trials
and when we do reach a we can view it as
the initial state of a new walk
so in one and two dimensions we have
probability one
of visiting every point with infinite
expected visits for each
recurrence at the origin implies
recurrence everywhere
now algebraically this all might be
convincing
but still why this abrupt change from
two to three dimensions
what ultimately clicked for me was
understanding that higher dimensional
walks
only behave like two-dimensional objects
expanding over time
alright what does that mean
to understand let's revisit the question
of average distance traveled
before we proved that the root mean
squared distance of a one-dimensional
walker's position
at step n is root n
it turns out that this square root
relationship holds in any number of
dimensions
let s n i be the i-coordinate of the
walker at step n
the expected squared distance along the
i-axis
will be equal to the number of steps
taken along that axis
so the expected squared total distance
is n
regardless of the dimensionality of the
walk
what if we ask a related question when
we first reach a distance r
how many steps do we expect to have
taken
similarly this ends up being r squared
steps
this is really the key suppose that
optimistically
when a three-dimensional walk reaches
distance r
all of its r-squared expected steps
visited distinct points
with zero repeats but the total number
of points within this distance will grow
like r
cubed as time goes on the walk will
cover an ever decreasing fraction of
these points
proportional to r squared over r cubed
or one over r and won't be able to catch
up
so the rate at which three-dimensional
walks move away from the origin
is too great relative to this coverage
rate
in the limit even though a
three-dimensional walk will visit
infinitely many points
it will only visit zero percent of the
entire state space
the origin can't be recurrent because we
know
as with the one and two dimensional
cases recurrence would imply
visiting every point and while sure it's
possible for it to return to the origin
a few times by chance
eventually it will get lost forever the
walk is like
an expanding two-dimensional object
because they exhibit similar ratios of
distance reached versus expected
coverage
if a circle lying on the z equals zero
plane begins expanding
when it reaches distance r it will only
have encompassed roughly
pi r-squared points an ever-decreasing
fraction of the bounding sphere
of radius r in two dimensions
the expected r squared steps ensure that
the walk never falls too far behind
the coverage rate ends up being
sufficient to eventually visit all the
points
infinitely many times with probability
1.
for some more on random walks and
various proofs of polio's recurrence
theorem
check out the links in the description
thanks for watching